China has made numerous solemn
representations to the US on the sale of
the f-16 V gesture Taiwan the US has to
bear all the consequences triggered by
the sale its eight billion US dollars
it's a lot of money that's a lot of jobs
and we know they're going to use these
f-16s responsibly the new deal to sell
f-16 fighter jets is worth eight billion
dollars it still needs to be approved by
the Senate if the deal does pass though
it will be the first sale of f-16s to
Taiwan since 1992 previous Taiwanese
requests for the jets were rejected by
the Obama administration last month the
US State Department approved another
arms deal with Taiwan it includes a
hundred and eight Abrams tanks and more
than 200 Stinger missiles the deal is
worth 2.2 billion dollars back then
Beijing also accused the u.s. of
meddling saying it would cut ties with
every American company involved in
selling arms to Taiwan
well Taiwan is officially recognized by
only 18 countries but the US has been
and has unofficially been supporting the
islands military since the 1980s China
sees Taiwan as part of its territory
you